una construcción en vigo camón en el
extremo sureste de abiyán muros en
concreto se han erigido de manera ilegal
todo esto sobrado de los ocupantes
ilegales si está vendido si lo ven así
es porque está vendido sin embargo esos
dos hombres pensaban haber hecho un buen
negocio en 2013 compraron una parcela
construible por una suma equivalente a 9
mil 700 dólares estas tierras les
pertenecen pero no las pueden explotar
según ellos unos mafiosos se las
apropiaron y están obteniendo ganancias
pueden ver que es reciente
vean esa línea de allá eso fue ayer
apenas ayer vea alrededor de cuatro mil
compradores afirman haber sido
despojados de sus bienes esta mañana
varias decenas de ellos se reúnen para
evaluar la situación todos poseen un acb
es decir un título de propiedad tenemos
nuestros acceder pero desafortunadamente
vienen a prohibirnos que construyan
cuando enviamos a obreros para trabajar
nos amenazan con machetes nos insultan
hoy obreros que él no conoce construyen
un muro en su propio terreno
nuestra presencia no pasó desapercibida
individuos amenazantes nos obligan a
abandonar el lugar los propietarios
están desesperados
todos los días comprobamos las palabras
de los ocupantes ilegales que nos dicen
que nuestros acceder para ellos son
papeles higiénicos porque hasta en el
comisariado o en el ministerio todas
esas personas están compradas entonces
no podemos hacer nada contra ellos
los propietarios acusan a las fuerzas
del orden y algunos agentes del
ministerio de construcción afirmaciones
graves haber sido sobornados por los
ocupantes pero el ministro de
construcción le pide a los propietarios
de yugo camón que presenten pruebas la
corrupción cuando la hay sucede entre
corruptor y el corrupto no es así como
podemos verlo si no estamos entre esas
dos personas informe nos muestra nos
información los sancionaremos nunca
tenemos información de este tipo
bruno con asegura que la situación
debería volver a la normalidad para los
propietarios expoliados
para nosotros el ministerio de
construcción los títulos en cuestión
siguen siendo 100% válidos
he dicho en varias ocasiones quienes
toman el riesgo de ir a construir que
mañana no vengan a jordan ante el
ministerio porque en realidad
se está corriendo un riesgo a título
personal entretanto los propietarios del
terreno en yugo camón aún no pueden
aprovechar sus bienes desde el café que
se le ofrece a las fuerzas del orden
hasta el billete que se le desliza al
funcionario para obtener un documento
administrativo la corrupción es parte de
la cotidianidad de los marfileños
según la ong transparencia internacional
en materia de corrupción
costa de marfil está en el puesto 106
entre 180 países
alrededor del 40 por ciento de la
población marfileña estima que la
corrupción aumenta cada año
la indisposición que eso quiere decir
que las disposiciones tomadas por el
estado para luchar contra la corrupción
no están dando los resultados esperados
tony brothers y tenemos tal como lo
muestra esta encuesta los policías y
agentes son percibidos por los
marfileños como los más corruptos pero
estos delitos no siempre quedan impunes
el tribunal militar de abiyán juzga a
los policías y agentes acusados de
extorsión
buenos días señores y señoras la
audiencia del tribunal militar del día
de hoy está abierta tomen asiento el
policía que comparece hoy es acusado de
haber aceptado un soborno contra la
garantía de que su cliente pasaría el
examen de ingreso a la escuela de
policía pero a pesar del pago de esta
suma la persona perdió el examen
ante la comprobación de este fracaso los
padres desamparados acudieron a la
justicia y pusieron una queja contra el
suboficial señor presidente él reconoció
sin rodeos los hechos que se le
reprocharon
unos minutos después se emite el
veredicto el suboficial es condenado a
dos años de prisión firme todos los
viernes los juicios se encadenan uno
tras otro pero son una gota de agua ante
la amplitud de la corrupción en diez
años sólo 413 expedientes de sobornos
han sido investigados sin embargo el
comisario del gobierno equivalente al
procurador afirma que ningún expediente
es ignorado nunca he recibido un
expediente que el ministerio se haya
negado a investigar y que lo sepan en
todas partes donde estén combatiremos
estos extorsionistas hasta el último
hasta el último que quede hasta la
última vista el tribunal militar de
abiyán es la única corte de este tipo en
costa de márfil reelegido en octubre
pasado el presidente alassane ouattara
prometió que la lucha contra la
corrupción sería una de las prioridades
de su tercer mandato para esto se nombró
especialmente a un ministro pero hasta
el momento no se ha anunciado ninguna
medida concreta para luchar contra este
problema